The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Let's
get started with Lecture 9.
Today's lecture is very
relevant to the homework.
We'll run through some
examples of performance models
like the ones you have
to work on or specify
an estimate on your homework.
So we talk about performance,
performance models.
What is performance?
What do we mean by performance?
Typically, this is a key
word used to describe output
and some sense of how well
the output service was, so
both in terms of the operator
and in terms of the passenger.
So things like running times,
waiting times, headways, things
that you can measure
from observations
of service being delivered,
we call that performance,
generally.
And the kinds of models
that we're going to look at
are wait time models,
service variation
along routes where you'll see
how it's not always the same.
You might start off at
the terminal one way
and end up a very different way.
We'll look at running time
models and dwell time models.
So these are the components
of running times.
Let's start with waiting time.
Well, before that, actually,
let's think about--
so here are some
kinds of models.
Why would we be interested
in modeling these things?
What applications can you think
of for these kinds of models?
That's two ways of
putting the same question.
Why would we be interested
in having a waiting time
model or a running time model?
Just give some examples.
Yeah, over in the back?
AUDIENCE: We want to understand
how people are waiting exactly.
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: But you
can go out and
measure it, right?
You can go out and do
a survey and observe
how people are waiting.
So why would a model be good?
What would a model do that
observations don't do?
AUDIENCE: For a new service.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
For a new service,
OK, we're starting to
get some ideas, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or changes in service.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Changes in service--
OK, so can you give
me an example of that?
AUDIENCE: Like [INAUDIBLE]
making the Victoria line 20%
more frequent.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK,
so if you increase frequency
on the Victoria line, what does
that do to demand and to dwell
time and to--
AUDIENCE: The Oxford Circuit is
now closed for 30 minutes a day
because can only
interchange, not enter.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
OK, so you
can try to use them to
predict service changes
or changes in performance
due to changes in service.
What else, any other ideas?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
service variation,
that's [INAUDIBLE] to crowded
and to crowded on the bus.
It's depending on how
the planned headway
sort of variance over time will
impact how many people end up
boarding on a bus.
Let's say, a bus that
came substantially
after the previous
bus might be crowded.
And I won't be able board.
And you might even have--
so denied boardings for--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
[INAUDIBLE]
will you summarize that?
Maybe I'll try summarizing.
You could use one
of these models
to fill in things
about performance
that you can't measure
directly from data.
So you gave an example of
measuring headways and then
estimating crowding on
the bus based on headways.
Was that more or less--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--getting at--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK,
trying to generalize a little
bit--
any other ideas?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: I mean, you could
use this as a [INAUDIBLE] model
in any other simulation.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Simulation models,
so if you want to do a
simulation model of a system
that has transit in it, you
need all these things to--
right?
Because you need to have
your [INAUDIBLE] which,
it could be a bus, or a
passenger waiting, or dwelling,
or moving between stops.
So you need these things.
Any other applications,
practical, very
practical applications?
So for dwell time and
running time models,
we all have our
prediction of when
the bus is coming to the stop.
So you need some model to take
the bus from where it is right
now, which you can
measure, to how long
will it take me to
reach this stop.
And so the passenger can look
up on the phone, how long will
I have to wait.
So these are all examples.
And there are more.
Let's start with waiting time.
So we've already seen this first
simple model of waiting time.
We say that the expected waiting
time is half the headway.
And here, we are considering
both waiting time and headway
to be stochastic quantities.
So if we observe many headways
over a long period of time,
we see a probability
distribution of headways.
And we're saying, the
average headway divided by 2
should equal the
average waiting time.
Now, this is a
very simple model.
And we know there are
some problems with it.
So we are assuming that
passengers arrive independent
of vehicle departure times.
We are assuming that
vehicles are departing
at equal intervals
deterministically,
so they're sort
of evenly spaced,
and that every
passenger can board
the first vehicle they see.
So nobody is left behind
by a bus that is too full.
So obviously, these
things don't always hold.
And particularly, the part
of vehicles departing exactly
at equal intervals doesn't hold.
It rarely holds.
AUDIENCE: Even if
they depart, there
are a lot of things along the
way that impact the variation.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so but we're
saying departing from each stop
deterministically, not just
the terminal.
So obviously, there are
some problems with this.
And so how do we need to--
well, if we start taking
care of some of these things,
what will happen
to waiting time?
Will it decrease or increase?
So if we take this
particular one.
This is the strongest
assumption, right?
So that vehicles depart
deterministically
at equal intervals--
and we say, no, they
don't, actually.
Some of them depart late.
Some of them depart early.
There is bunching.
So what happens to waiting
time when that happens?
AUDIENCE: It goes up.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It goes up.
So how do we adjust this
model to account for that?
Let's look at that.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
it depend though
when the passengers
are arriving?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: If
you look at an average or a long
period of time, and you'd have
the same number of vehicles
and drivers, so you either-- the
best thing you can do if people
are arriving randomly is to--
AUDIENCE: OK, they're
arriving randomly.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so we're
only tackling that assumption.
OK, so there are some
issues, as we said.
There is bulk arrivals.
So you have a bus stop right
outside of a train station.
And the train has just left.
And a bunch of people
get off the train
and they all want
to board the bus.
That's not being
captured by this.
And we can think of the
passenger arrival process
in steps, from
having no information
to having a lot of information.
So random arrivals
is what we typically
assume, certainly for
high-frequency service,
and in some cases, for
all kinds of service.
And that's more problematic.
If you know how
long-headway service,
people are going to try
to time their arrival
at the stop to the schedule.
But you will see
some models that--
in the literature,
that, for simplicity,
especially service planning
models, for simplicity,
might assume this anyway.
You have a question.
AUDIENCE: Like random,
but Poisson distributed,
or just, like, random?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah,
Poisson distributed-- sometimes
it could just be random.
Typically the assumption made
is that it's a Poisson process.
So inter-arrival times
are negative exponential
distribution.
OK, then some passengers
will time their arrivals
to minimum waiting.
So this could be that you have
a phone app or a schedule.
And you show up a couple
of minutes before.
You're trying to minimize
your waiting time.
You're trying to arrive shortly
before the vehicle departs.
And then there is the
running to the vehicle
before it leaves the stop, and
therefore, I have no waiting.
That's everyone's
favorite, right?
So if we look at a graph
of expected headway
on the horizontal axis
and expected waiting
time on the vertical
axis, you will
see that around 10 minutes--
some people say 15, some people
say 10, but somewhere around
there, 12--
so you will see that
the actual waiting
time that you would observe
is much lower than what
the simple model
says it is, which
is half the headway for headways
longer than 10, 12, 15 minutes.
And I think those people
will have some strategy
to minimize their waiting time.
So below that amount, people
tend to not time their arrivals
at stops.
And they tend to arrive
randomly, essentially.
So if you try to take the
Red line here in Boston,
you just show up
at whatever time.
And typically, most people
won't be looking at their phone
and trying to time their
arrival, although that
is happening increasingly.
So for those people, the
model, the simple model
of headway divided by 2
tends to underestimate
the actual waiting time.
And that's due to headway
variability, mostly.
So we have to take care
of that assumption.
Let's look at a formulation
that relaxes that.
Let's say that vehicle
departures are not
regular and deterministic.
So let's refine the model
to take care of that.
So let's define n as
a function of headway
to be the number of
passengers arriving
at some headway and the mean
waiting time of headway, h,
to be, well, that mean headway
of some specific headway
that we observe, and then g
to be the probability density
function of headway.
So we observe many
of these highways.
And we have a
histogram of headways.
So if you want to compute
the expected waiting
time across all
passengers, what we want
is the expected total
passenger waiting
time divided by the expected
number of passengers
over many, many observations
of vehicles leaving.
And that is expressed
mathematically in the equation
below.
We have integrals, in this
case, from 0 to infinity,
because headways
can't be negative,
so we're not going from negative
infinity to positive infinity.
And we're saying, yeah,
for any given headway,
we'll multiply the
number of people times
how much they wait
on average times
the probability that
I see that headway.
And let's integrate over
all possible headways
and divide that by the number
of people on each headway.
Does that make
sense conceptually?
OK, so now let's make
some assumptions.
Let's say that people
do arrive uniformly
with some rate, lambda.
And so the number of people
arriving in a given headway
is going to be some arrival
rate, which we've said
is constant, times the headway.
So if we say that 10
people arrive per minute,
and lambda therefore is
10 passengers per minute,
then if the headway is 2
minutes, we have 20 people.
Does that make sense?
Any questions so far?
OK, and then--
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
just what you said there?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so lambda
is the passenger arrival rate.
And I gave an example of it
being 10 passengers per minute.
So is that something
you measure.
And we're assuming
that that amount
is constant for a specific time
of day at a specific place.
And then we're saying,
if you-- once you
assume that, then you observe
a headway, which could be, say,
2 minutes long.
Then you multiply
by the arrival rate.
Now we say it's 20 passengers
for that particular headway.
And there might be another
headway that is 5 minutes long.
That's 50 people--
1 minute long, 10
people, and so forth.
And then for each
of those headways,
the average waiting
time is going
to be half of that
headway, correct?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
We're assuming
people arrive randomly, so
within a particular headway,
this is true.
There's no problem
with this assumption
as long as you are
comfortable with assuming
that people arrive randomly.
So now we have this equation
for expected waiting time.
Let me write on the board how we
get to that from the integrals.
Can somebody say why--
so why is it the case that, when
we have headway variability,
the waiting time goes up?
What's the concept
that leads to that?
Eli?
AUDIENCE: There
is unreliability,
and so people need to build in
more [INAUDIBLE] time instead
of--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
There is
something else that is sort
of more fundamental happening.
AUDIENCE: A bus that
comes at a larger headway
than it was planned
will actually
be collecting more people.
So more people will
be waiting more time.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
from a passenger's perspective,
the probability of arriving
during a long headway
is greater than arriving
during a short headway.
What is that called?
There is a name for that that's
important in transportation.
Random-- random incidence, so
this is something you, if you
took 200, you should know that.
But it's good to know,
random incidence.
It's called the random
incidence paradox,
because people without-- if you
don't think about it too much,
you say it's half the headway.
And then somebody says, no,
actually the average waiting
time is much longer.
Why is that?
And you have to sort
of solve the paradox.
It isn't really a
paradox, but here we are.
So the expected waiting time--
we'll start from the
equation, the last equation
on slide four.
And we're just going to plug
in what our assumption is.
So we have integral
from 0 to infinity.
And we said we had n of h.
And we said that that's
going to be lambda h.
So let's just put
that in, lambda h.
And then we said,
for waiting time,
we said it was going
to be 1/2, so 1/2 h.
And then we're going to
multiply times the PVF
the probability of
that headway times dh.
All right, and here
we have the same,
but without the waiting time.
So that's just
substitution, shouldn't
be anything wrong with that.
So now, lambda and 1/2 come out.
They're not a function of
h, so they are constants.
We can take them out.
And we are left with, let's see,
lambda over 2 integral from 0
to infinity of h squared--
because we have two h's here--
times dh dh.
And here we have--
lambda comes out.
And we integrate from 0
to infinity of h dh dh.
OK, now the first
observation is that lambda
has come out on both sides.
So there's just one lambda on
the top, one on the bottom,
so we can cancel them out.
So that's very convenient.
What does that mean?
This happens because
we are assuming
that lambda is constant.
That wouldn't happen
if it weren't constant.
But that's convenient, right?
So now we have some
quantity that does not
depend on the arrival rate.
So the same equation is
not affected by that.
And let's see if
we can recognize
what these quantities are.
So let's start with
the one on the bottom.
This is the definition
of the expectancy.
So this is just the average.
So we're essentially
saying, take every--
take the average headway,
so take every headway,
and multiply times the
probability of observing it.
Add them all up.
That's what the average is.
So we have 2 times
the expected headway.
And at the top, we have the
expectants of h squared.
So I think that takes
us to where we are
on this slide, which is great.
So part of it was
just recognizing
that that was the definition
of expectants, so that's great.
And now, somehow, we go
from here to this equation.
It's not entirely clear,
but it's convenient
that variance is a function of
the expectants of h squared.
So I'll just remind you,
if you haven't seen it,
then introduce you to the
definition-- or not quite
the definition, actually.
This is you take the
definition and you expand it
and collect like terms.
And then you get that
the variance of h
is the expectation of h squared
minus the expectation of h
quantity squared, so means
of square minus squares mean.
You might have seen that before.
So essentially, if we solve that
equation for expectation of h
squared and plug that in here,
we can collect like terms
and get this last equation.
So now we have that
the expected waiting
time is half the headway
times some adjustment factor.
And that adjustment factor
is 1 plus some amount--
that amount is what we call
the coefficient of variation--
squared.
So coefficient of variation
is standard deviation
divided by mean.
So we have normalizing
the standard deviation.
You square that quantity.
You add it to 1.
And that'll increase your
waiting time by some amount.
Let's stop here for a second.
Any questions with the
derivation and what
the meaning of this is?
Yes, Henry?
AUDIENCE: Can you
go back to that step
where you went from the
integral to 2 e of h.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
this is a matter of definition.
So this here, the
integral from 0--
from negative infinity to
positive infinity of some
amount times the probability of
observing that amount over all
possibilities of the amount--
that's why we go from negative
infinity to positive infinity--
equals the average
of that amount,
or the expectation
of that amount.
So that part-- do
you understand?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes?
And then here, we're
just saying, well,
this is the same thing,
except of the amount instead
of being h is h squared.
So we're taking the
average of h squared.
This comes from here to
here from the definition
of expectation.
And the reason we're not
going from negative infinity
to positive infinity
is that h can only
take non-negative values.
It can be 0 or higher.
So it's the same thing to
integrate from 0 to infinity,
in that case.
Does that clear up the question?
Any other questions?
So now we have this modified
model of waiting time,
mainly for
high-frequency service,
where people are
arriving randomly
but vehicles are not
necessarily departing stops
deterministically on
equal intervals anymore.
Now these vehicles can come--
as long as they come independent
of the passenger arrival
process, it doesn't really
matter how they come.
This model calculates
the expected waiting time
across all passengers.
So we have some cases
that we can look at.
First case is simple.
Let's say that
the variance is 0.
That means we go back
to the assumption of,
well, if the variance
of headway is 0,
vehicles are arriving exactly
every five minutes, say.
They're deterministically
at equally spaced intervals.
So we then have that the
coefficients of variation is 0.
And we end up with the
same thing we had before.
So that really checks out
with our previous model
in that special case, but
we generalized the model.
So we can try it with different
vehicle arrival or departure
processes.
One that we have here is, let's
say that vehicle departures are
a Poisson process.
So this would mean that they are
arriving randomly, essentially,
and that the time of arrival
of a vehicle at a stop
is independent of any
other previous arrival.
So that would be a good
model for a service that
is controlled very loosely.
They are hardly controlled.
So you essentially
sometimes see bunching.
Sometimes you don't.
Sometimes you have
a long headway.
Sometimes you don't.
So the definition-- if you go
through the Poisson process
and look at the definitions of
the probability distributions
of inter-arrival
times, et cetera,
you will see that the
variance in such a process
is the square of
the expectation, so
the square of the mean.
And if we plug that
into our equation,
we get that the expected waiting
time is the expected headway.
So people are essentially
waiting about as long
as your mean headway,
which is a bad situation.
You've doubled
their waiting time
from half the headway
to the full headway.
If you have a system where
your vehicles are all bunched
and you're running
pairs of bunches,
that's more or less what
you get, because you have--
if you had vehicles
every 5 minutes, now
you have two vehicles every 10.
Your average headway is
five, but your waiting time
is now five as well.
OK, what about the third case?
The headway sequence is
5, 15, 5, 15, 5, 15--
thank you, keep going like
that, so not quite bunched
all the way, but there
is a lot of variability.
So I'm saying that the
expected headway is 10.
Does that make sense?
It's 5, 15, 5, 15.
The average of
that process is 10.
So we have an average
headway of 10.
And now what's the
expected waiting time?
So it helps to draw a timeline
and to divide that timeline
into pieces, so 5, 15, 5, 15.
So we have vehicles arriving
or departing here, here, here,
and here.
And there is a
five-minute headway here,
and a 15-minute headway here,
a five-minute headway there,
and a 15-minute headway here.
And people are
arriving randomly.
People arrive independent
of this process.
So what you'll see is
that, the first thing
is, if you were to arrive
on a five-minute headway,
the average waiting
time for you would
be half of that five-minute
headway, 2 and 1/2 minutes.
And if you arrive on
15-minute headway,
then your expected
waiting time, given
that you arrive on a 15-minute
headway is 7 and 1/2 minutes.
So that's the 2.5 and
the 7.5 on this equation.
And then we have
the probabilities
of having arrived on
any of those headways.
Because the 15-minute
headway is 3 times longer
than the 5-minute headway,
you are 3 times more
likely to arrive during
a 15-minute headway
than during a 5-minute headway.
So therefore, 25% of
passengers will arrive
on the 15-minute headways.
And you essentially
computing a weighted average,
so 6 and 1/4 minutes.
Questions on this?
All right, another
assumption that we
were looking at
in the first model
that we are still
having in this model
is that people can
board the first vehicle
that they see arrive.
So no vehicle is too
full to take passengers.
No vehicle is leaving
people behind.
That's not true.
If we look at any
process, and we say here
that w0 is the
expected waiting time
when people can board
their first vehicle,
so when no vehicle
is full, and we then
look at all the expected waiting
times for passengers including
passengers that are left
behind, when that capacity is
being reached--
so here on the
horizontal, we have rho,
which is flow over capacity.
You may have seen this
kind of relationship
from queuing theory.
So when rho is 0, it means
that you will have some supply
and nobody is using it.
If rho is 0.5,
then your capacity
is double of the demand.
That's OK usually.
If rho is 1, you are--
your capacity
equals your demand.
And what we see is that
the expected waiting
time for service will
start to approach infinity.
There is a term that we use
in, say, queuing theory,
for such a system.
Does anybody know it?
We say that the system
blows up when this happens.
If you hear that,
you'll see that.
If you take any sort of queuing
theory, you'll hear that.
So as rho equals 1, let's
say that you have-- you're
providing a bus
service with capacity
for 100 people per minute.
That's pretty high.
And then your demand equals
100 people per minute.
So if people are
arriving uniformly,
you might just provide
a capacity for everyone.
And nobody is being left behind.
But that doesn't happen,
because people arrive randomly.
Some people will leave with
some remaining capacity.
And the next vehicle won't have
enough space for that person.
And then the vehicles
themselves will not
arrive perfectly
evenly, so now you
have a chain reaction of
people waiting and not
being able to board.
And unless you
supply more capacity,
unless you increase
the capacity,
you're going to have more
and more people waiting
and being left behind.
So the actual
expected waiting time
would increase as your ratio of
flow to capacity approaches 1.
That's the takeaway here.
And you could think of
two different lines, one
for low reliability when
there is a lot of bunching,
and therefore, a lot of the
capacity that you provide
is wasted on small
headways that are not
serving as many passengers as
you assign them for, and then
high reliability,
where, yes, you still
have some variability
that you can't control.
You've done what you can.
And this is relatively
high reliability,
but still you have
some variability,
and therefore, you can't expect
to reach that rho equals 1.
It'll still blow up when you--
as you approach 1.
But it's closer to
1, so that's good.
Questions on this relationship?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: What do most
bus services operate
at [INAUDIBLE]?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I don't have a number
off the top of my head.
It varies a lot.
And it varies a lot
of by time period.
So some services here in Boston
operate during the peak leaving
people behind every day.
If you look at some of
the most crowded stations
in the tube in London, certainly
they have to meter people
going into stations.
So they may have approached rho
greater than 1, in this case.
But it's non-stationary.
So that's during the
peak of the peak.
And then the demand falls,
so eventually, those people
are served, of course,
because the supply is kept up
at some-- at the highest
rate that they can keep it.
And demand it comes
down, so it stabilizes.
Any other questions?
That's a good question.
All right, so service
variation along
routes-- so we've been
talking about vehicles
leaving on time or not
on time, and bunching.
So here's what happens.
This is a space-time diagram.
Have we seen these diagrams
on this course yet?
AUDIENCE: No.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No-- OK, well this
is a very important diagram
in public transportation,
certainly.
AUDIENCE: And the
homework says to make one.
So we should probably--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Great.
AUDIENCE: --learn it.
I was wondering what it was.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
This is a space-time diagram.
You have space on the y-axis
and time on the x-axis.
And what you see
are some lines that
show how a vehicle is moving
across space and time.
So there are variations of this.
Sometimes people put time
on the vertical and space
on the horizontal.
That's fine.
And typically, you see
little steps for each stop,
because if a vehicle is
stopped, time is running
and the vehicle is not moving,
so you see little steps.
So you can see holding.
You can see dwell times.
You can see speeds.
You can see recovery time
at a terminal, everything
on this diagram.
So it's a great diagram
for analyzing service.
AUDIENCE: When we make,
should we make them like this?
Or like--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
The little steps are--
AUDIENCE: Little steps--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, I mean, they're helpful.
You'll see dwell times, so yeah.
So this is a conceptual
very simplified diagram,
but here is the idea.
So you have some scheduled
trajectories in dashed lines.
So we're essentially planning
to run service every 10 minutes,
departing from Stop 1 at
9:00, 9:10, 9:20, et cetera.
And if things run
according to plan,
you will keep a 10-minute
headway throughout the route.
But that's not what happens.
If we observe-- let's
say that the driver that
was driving the bus
that departed at 9:10
is a slow driver, so that
driver drives slowly.
So therefore, more time passes
covering the same space.
And then let's say that the
9:20 driver is a fast driver.
So that driver covers more
distance in less time.
And they bunch.
They meet somewhere before they
reach the end of the route.
They've platooned.
And they're running
together as a bunch.
So what does that do to headway?
AUDIENCE: What does
what do to headway?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: What
does this process of bunching
do to headways?
AUDIENCE: It increases.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right?
Headways are increasing,
because now you've--
well, the average
headway remains the same,
because you have a
0 and a big number.
But what people actually
see are the long headways,
because the chance of
arriving and just catching
the 30-second headway
is much smaller.
So people are waiting more
because these headways are
longer.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, you probably
have more people waiting.
So there is [INAUDIBLE]--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so there's
a vicious cycle here, right?
Yeah, we'll get to
that on the next slide.
AUDIENCE: It would be better
if the fast driver got
in front of the slow driver.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah,
we'll talk about that too.
We'll talk about that too.
OK, so do we understand
this process of bunching?
Here is what you were
talking about, Ari?
So there is an issue
when that happens.
So now we have the
little steps here.
So this is Step 2, Step 3.
And these are the dwell times.
So nothing happened on bus one.
It ran exactly as planned in
this hypothetical example.
But because this driver was
slow, the headway was bigger.
And more people arrived
during the headway.
So now the dwell
times at Stop 2 are
going to be longer for that
driver that was driving slow.
Now that bus has
more passengers.
And therefore, the probability
of stopping at the next stop
is higher, because
you have more people,
so the chance that at least
one person on that bus
wants to get off at
the next one is higher.
And if the bus is
really crowded,
the dwell time process is
going to be slowed down
by just friction
between passengers.
So this bus continues
to be delayed, not just
by the driver driving slow,
but by the dwell time effect.
And because that bus
is being delayed,
fewer people are arriving to
see the next bus, the third bus.
The dwell times of that third
bus are shorter than planned.
Fewer people are
waiting for that bus.
And therefore, that bus
has a lower probability
of having to stop.
And if it stops, fewer
people will board it.
So that bus is
going to run fast.
Even if the drivers are now
driving at the same speed,
there is nothing you can do.
They will bunch.
Well, there is something you
can-- you can control them.
And that's a later
topic in the course.
So they pair or they bunch,
that's what we're saying.
OK, so if we think
about how if you
were to survey headways
of different points
along the route,
you would see that,
if you start at a terminal--
this is like a probability
density function,
but they're not normalized.
So don't think about scale.
So you have headway
on the horizontal.
And the probability
density on the vertical.
And so at the terminal or close
to the start of the route,
you will see something
bell-shaped usually.
It'll be around the
scheduled departure time,
or around the headway.
And there will be some
variability due to drivers
not being exactly on time when
they leave, and supervision
issues, or whatever it is.
So maybe the boarding
process at the first stop
introduces some perturbations.
But it's essentially
bell-shaped.
And it has less variability.
As you move to the
middle of the route,
you'll see that
the bell is being--
it's getting fatter and fatter
tails, so more variability
in the headway because
of the bunching problem
that we just described.
Usually by the time you
see bunching, your--
which could be at the end, or
it could be before the end,
you'll have this
distribution with two spots,
a lot of vehicles having
headway of 0 or very close to 0,
and a lot of headways
longer than that
by some amount with
a lot of variability.
So these are pairs
that are arriving.
So every time you see a pair
arriving, one of them is 0.
And the other one is
some longer headway.
And they are affecting these
two parts of the probability
distribution.
Is that understood?
Any questions?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So the big
point you're talking about
is the lower--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So essentially--
AUDIENCE: --the lower curve?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: --it's
just, yes, this one right here.
So essentially, it's just
higher variability of headways.
So variability of headways
tends to be minimized
at the start of a run.
And then that degrades.
It increases as you run the
route until you have bunching.
And when you have bunching,
you reach this point
of having some vehicles that
are close to 0 and others
that are anywhere else.
So that means the
waiting time is
a function of
headway as scheduled,
also of headway reliability.
So if you're running a service
that is well controlled
and you have good headways, then
you may never reach this point.
And you may actually
have everything
running somewhat bell-shaped,
not too much variance.
That's your ideal situation.
And then it's also a function of
where you are along the route.
So if you're closer to a
controlled point, which
could be the
terminal, or it could
be anywhere along the route,
if there is control en route,
then you will have less
variability of headways.
As you run downstream of
the last control point,
then you will see
greater variability.
Great, so what factors affect
the headway deterioration?
Length of route is one.
So if he no longer route, then
it takes an hour and a half
to cover the whole one-direction
run, the half cycle,
then this deterioration has--
that process has more
time to act on the route.
So you will see more headway
unreliability, more bunching.
The marginal dwell time per
passengers is another factor.
If you think of--
well, we just saw that
the bunching process
is largely affected
by dwell time,
because if you have
a longer headway,
more people are boarding.
So if you think
of an extreme case
where everybody boards
and alights instantly,
then you don't have
that effect anymore.
So to the extent that
people can board and alight
fast relative to the time
it takes to run the service,
then this effect
diminishes to the extent
that dwell time is
a larger percentage
of the total runtime.
Then it increases.
You have more bunching.
The stopping
probability-- again,
this has to do with
how many people
are on the bus and
the stop spacing.
If stops are spaced very
close to each other,
then you have a higher
variance of where you stop.
if you have a long
distance between stations,
if you think of a
commuter rail line,
then you're going to
stop at every stop.
And therefore, you
decrease the variability
of this effect of stopping.
So you have the urban
bus route in one hand
and the commuter rail with
long distances between stops,
and therefore stopping at
every stop, on the other hand.
The schedule headway
has an impact.
If you schedule the
headways every 30 minutes,
it's unlikely
you'll see bunching.
But if you schedule the
headways every two minutes, then
it's very easy for
you to see bunching.
You have to control
this very well
to avoid bunching in that case.
And driver behavior--
if your vehicles
are driven by very good
drivers or computers
on the extreme right, driven
with driverless trains,
then you can really
sort of try to make up
for all of these
things in driving
and try to keep things even.
If they are drivers that are
not particularly well trained
and have not received feedback,
for example, on their driving
speeds and other behavior,
and not just that,
but also being on
time at the terminal
and leaving exactly on
time, things like that,
would all affect this.
So here is a simple model of
how headway will deteriorate.
So there is also a mistake
on the integration.
That should be p i, not p i
minus 1, sorry about that.
So we have that the headway
deviation at some stop--
here, we're thinking
about a scheduled headway
and the actual headway we see.
So if service is running
exactly on time, ei is 0.
If that bus is delayed,
then ei is positive.
And if it's running
early, ei is negative.
So you start out--
you go from one
stop to the next.
And the deviation of
headway you see at some stop
is going to be a
function of how--
what the deviation was
at the previous stop.
So if you're already
delayed, your chances
of being delayed at the
next stop are higher.
That should make sense.
Then you add the effect of
running from that previous stop
to this stop.
If you are particularly
slow doing that,
then your delay will increase.
If you try to drive fast
to make up for that,
then ti will be negative.
And it will decrease the impact
on headway deterioration.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do they ever just--
so this seems to imply that,
like, maybe I could
fix my problem
by just dropping a
bus from the schedule.
Like, let's say I
was really behind,
I could just delay
all the other buses
and, like, take up the
schedule of the next--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, but you will have--
you still have a headway,
a longer headway, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So you could make up
your schedule that way.
But you're essentially doing an
accounting trick by doing that.
You can make your vehicles
look like they're all
running on time by doing that.
And you dropped one trip.
But you still have a
longer headway here
and shorter headways there,
and passengers boarding
mostly that delayed vehicle.
And so from a
passenger's perspective,
that doesn't do much.
But then you have to
consider the effect of, well,
you might have--
you might want to do
that if your drivers
need to check out
at some time in the day.
And your options are
either, you do this now,
or at some time when they check
out, you have to drop trips.
And that could be
during the peak.
So that would be
really bad, right?
So then you would have to
consider that strategy.
AUDIENCE: And do buses
typically post, like,
a scheduled time
that they're supposed
to arrive at each stop?
Because normally--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --I see, like--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--especially now,
so typically--
AUDIENCE: Like
up-to-date minutes.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So London will say that.
So if it's high frequency--
and London, the
threshold is 12 minutes.
So anything below, they'll
say, AM peak between--
expect service every eight
minutes, for example.
And then as soon as the
headway increases above that,
they'll say the times.
But if you look at service
here, for example, here
in Boston, every bus route here,
if you look at the DTFS file,
has specific times at each
stop, even though DTFS
has the option of
giving a headway
for high-frequency service,
they don't do that here.
AUDIENCE: So only service
[INAUDIBLE] time appear?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, but those DTFS file
has times at every stop.
So yeah, and that's
another thing,
that if you look at
printed schedules that
are posted somewhere
and on paper,
typically they'll
have the terminals
and some time points in between
and not every single stop.
AUDIENCE: And the time points
[INAUDIBLE] approximately
[INAUDIBLE]?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Well, that
depends on the control
policy of that agency.
So we'll talk more about
control in a later lecture.
So typically, you don't
control at every stop.
You control at, sometimes, just
the terminal, and sometimes
at the terminal and some
key points in between.
And those are timing
points for control.
OK, so back to this model, the
headway deviation at some stop
is, you start out from what
it was in the previous stop.
You add the effect
of running time
to that stop from
the previous one.
And then you add the effect
of dwell time, essentially.
So this pi, not pi minus
1, as I said earlier--
and so this is the arrival
rate at the stop right now
and multiplied by the
boarding time per passenger.
So this whole quantity is
multiplied by this amount,
which is the time it takes--
it's the deviation of the
time it takes to arrive.
So it's a deviation in
headway, essentially.
So if you're headway is now
a minute longer than it used
to be, then you will have
a minute times the boarding
rate per passenger times the
arrival rate of passengers,
extra people boarding,
or extra time, extra time
of dwell time
affecting that bus,
and therefore slowing
it down further.
Does that make sense?
Or should I break it
down a little bit?
AUDIENCE: Did not answer
that question, but just
to ask a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
interrupt anyone else.
AUDIENCE: So is this
accounting for the fact
that, if there is no one
getting on or off this stop,
the first person to
pull into a stop,
decelerate, and open the door
takes a given amount of time.
And the marginal time
to add an extra person
is quite small, or
relatively small.
Is that accounted for here?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No, this model
is saying that it's
a linear effect.
You're not saying that
the first person takes--
AUDIENCE: So two would take
twice as long as one person.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Exactly, yeah,
so that is a
simplification here.
And it's a point
that we will address
towards the end of this lecture.
AUDIENCE: OK, [INAUDIBLE]
asking questions.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Good segues,
that's, like, the
second one today.
AUDIENCE: This is only
extra [INAUDIBLE] right?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So yeah, exactly,
because this is a model
of headway deviation.
So you have this passenger
arrival rate and the boarding
time, but because you're
only multiplying it--
you're not multiplying it
times the whole headway.
You're multiplying times
the headway deviation, which
is the deviation at this stop
when you arrive and this stop.
It's the deviation
when you were arriving
at the previous stop plus
the time it took you to reach
this stop from that time.
So now you have adjusted-- now
you have the deviation arriving
at this stop.
If your headway is
a minute longer,
than you need to add however
much extra dwell time
you have to pick up that
extra minute of passengers.
An that's what that
last case is doing.
AUDIENCE: So at the
beginning, the e
will be 0 at the first stop?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Hopefully.
It depends on your
control policy.
So if you depart your terminal
and your driver didn't show up
on time and they left a minute
late from the even headway,
then you start out with
one minute deviation.
So yeah, hopefully that
is 0 at the beginning.
And then due to effect
that we described here,
it starts deteriorating.
And this is a
mathematical model to--
a simple mathematical
model to account for that.
So it's still a
deterministic one.
Here is a probabilistic one.
The details for this
formulation are on this paper.
If you're interested,
let me know.
I will send it you.
What I want to highlight
here are the quantities.
So this is a model
of headway variance.
So we are looking
at, now, headway
as a stochastic quantity.
And we're calculating
the variance of headway
at some stop.
And again, we see
the same pattern.
We see that it depends on what
it was at the previous stop.
And then we add the effect
of the running time,
so the variance of running
times between consecutive stops,
to the extent that the drivers
are different in driving,
then this variance increases.
And then you have
these two terms--
really, three terms, that
have to do with dwell time.
All of these terms have--
the q here is the mean number
of passengers per bus served.
And c is the marginal dwell time
per passenger-- so different
notation from the model that we
just saw, but same quantities.
So we have something times
that probability is--
the bus will skip
a stop, et cetera.
So all these things together are
accounting for the dwell time
effect.
So the last term here
is, again, looking
at c, which is the marginal
dwell time per passenger.
So this also has to
do with dwell time.
But this one is also multiplied
by the covariance with headway.
So this is that effect of the
relationship between headway
and sort of passenger
arrivals, captured here
as the covariance between
those two quantities.
So the key takeaway
from this slide
is not exactly why this
is the right equation.
If you're interested in
that, read the paper.
I am interested in
understanding what
goes into this equation in
terms of what components
lead to a higher variance
at some particular stop.
OK, we are ready to move to
vehicle running time models
if no-- if there
are no questions
on waiting time headway models.
OK, so let's do that.
So different levels of detail--
we have some models
that are very detailed.
There are microscopic model.
It's a simulation.
And they look at the vehicle
motion, the interaction
with other vehicles.
So you might have private
automobiles interacting
with a bus, for example, and
traffic blocking the bus.
And you have signals.
So every little
detail is modeled.
That's a microscopic model.
On the other hand, you
have macroscopic models,
which are not looking
at all those details.
Instead, they're saying, what
are the running times that I
observe as a function
of time of day,
and the driver,
different components.
And macroscopically, we say,
this is the running time.
So there is something in
between called mesoscopic, when
you have some parts
that are detailed
and others that are not--
so different levels of modeling.
So running time, as
we know, includes
dwell time, the movement time
between stops, and any delays.
Delays could be because of
signals, traffic signals,
for example.
So dwell time is a
function of the number
of passengers
boarding and arriving
as well as technology
characteristics.
What are some examples of
technology characteristics
that could affect dwell times?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
cards, smart card.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
what your fare card technology,
so if you have smart cards,
or coins, paying cash--
very different, right?
What else?
AUDIENCE: Off-board
fare collection.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Off-board fare collection--
so if you remove the
payment from the vehicle,
then that really helps with
decreasing the variability.
What else?
AUDIENCE: All boarding.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: All boarding?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
All-door boarding?
AUDIENCE: All-door boarding.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So boarding
through all doors--
of course, if you
can board through
multiple doors,
you have a faster dwell time
process in this variable.
What else?
AUDIENCE: If the station
level is the same as the--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Level boarding--
so if people don't have to
climb steps to go from the curb
to the vehicle, that also helps.
Any other ideas?
Eli?
AUDIENCE: The type
of the bus stop--
am I pulling into a cutout and
then I have to wait for traffic
to merge back in.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] stay
in the lane [INAUDIBLE]----
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And that
depends on the
definition of dwell time.
So if you say dwell time is
only the amount of time needed
to serve passengers, then that
shouldn't really be a factor.
But if you think of the
dwell time as the whole time
it took me to stop
and serve that stop,
then this would be included.
So you're looking at--
let's see if I can get at
this, clean a section here.
So one example is
a bus bay here.
So this is a bus
stop right here.
And maybe this is
an intersection.
So the bus comes in here.
And it's waiting there.
But if there is traffic and
there are cars right here,
after that bus is
ready, it may have to--
well, if it's right of
the signal, it's fine.
But if this now merges
and there is traffic here,
then that bus might be
sort of stuck enough
to maneuver its way back
into the traffic flow.
So a [INAUDIBLE] sign or
stop sign have an impact.
What else?
Henry?
AUDIENCE: If you're
serving a line where
there are a lot of
people who are, like,
tourists and people,
like, ask questions,
it could take forever
to get on to the bus.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's not a technology
characteristic, but
it is a valid factor
that affects dwell times.
Or maybe if your technology
is very complicated
and people have a
lot of questions,
that could be a way to--
AUDIENCE: Or maybe
a lack of technology
where, like, you don't have--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So OK,
I think we gave good examples.
If we look at the
typical bus running time
and how we break
it down, this is
a typical bus in mixed traffic.
Somewhere between
a 1/2 and 3/4 will
be spent moving between stops.
Between 10 and a 1/4--
10% and 1/4 will be spent
at stops, serving the stop.
And between 10% and
1/4 will be served
in traffic or waiting
for a signal, so at
a red light, essentially.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] about this
a bit, but in movement time,
would that include all the
time it takes for me to, like,
stop the bus?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Again,
it depends on your definition.
But yes, I think in
this break down, yes.
So the slowing down
and accelerating
is sort of in there, yeah.
Any other questions?
OK, so let's look at
some dwell time models.
Dwell times models are a
component of running time
models, because dwell times
are one of the key pieces
of running times.
And actually, another point
about these, movement time,
dwell time, and delay,
which of those three
do you think the agency
has most control over?
AUDIENCE: Dwell time.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Dwell time, right?
Why?
Can an agency usually diminish
traffic or do something
about traffic signals?
There are some things you
can do, but usually not.
It's harder.
And movement time, that has
to do with traffic and speed
limits, and the vehicle
itself, and driver behavior.
So that's a little
bit harder to change.
So dwell times are
probably the one thing
here that an agency will target.
Some part of it,
you can't change,
because it has to do with how
many people are at the stop.
But you could
increase frequency.
You could change
the bus assigned.
We gave a bunch of factors.
And a lot of those are
in control of the agency,
so under the control
of the agency.
So let's go to the dwell
time models for that reason.
There are some examples here,
three papers, one on bus dwell
time, one on light rail dwell
times for the Green line,
and one on heavy rail.
So we're going to look
at the three of them,
just a high-level overview.
So let's look at
some concepts first.
Vehicle dwell times
affect system performance.
We've discussed why and how.
And they affect service quality.
We've also discussed
why and how.
They are a critical element
in vehicle bunching.
I think that has
also been covered.
So they result in high headway
variability, high passenger
waiting times, and
uneven passenger loads.
That last point,
we have mentioned,
but it was indirectly--
the point has been
made indirectly, right?
If more people are
arriving at some stop,
at some bus that has
a longer headway,
not only did those
people wait longer,
but they are boarding
a more crowded bus.
So their experience
in the vehicle
is also going to be diminished.
It's going to be a
lower-quality experience.
So we've covered that.
Dwell time impact on performance
depends on substation spacing,
the mean dwell as a
proportion of trip time,
the mean headway, and
operations control procedures.
We have touched upon, not
necessarily what can be done,
but we know that there are some
things you can do to diminish
the headway variability.
Any examples of that, actually?
Anybody have suggestions
on what can be done?
Eli?
AUDIENCE: You tell the bus
that is trailing to, like,
wait longer.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, you
try to slow down the buses
that are running fast.
So there's different
ways of doing that.
You can tell the
driver to drive slowly.
You can hold buses at
stops for control points.
So you tell them, do not depart.
You have to wait a
minute before you depart,
because you're running
too fast, and you're
going to catch up
to the previous bus.
So that's called holding.
So there has been a lot
of research and holding
strategies.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
the more typical thing
would be telling them to hold?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It seems
weird to ask someone
to slow down in traffic.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Eh, it's been done.
AUDIENCE: Really?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I wouldn't like
to be that bus driver.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: You
would kind of surreptitiously
and only a little bit.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: And
people don't like being held.
So driving a little bit slow is
less obvious to the passengers.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yes, you have a
bus hold just a few seconds
when the light changes.
[INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I could
really get you--
AUDIENCE: So that's sort
of the best hold strategy.
Oh, we just missed it.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
OK, so there
are operations
controlled procedures
that can be used here.
So some examples based on
these factors, on the one
hand you have commuter rail.
We gave that example earlier.
Little impact of dwell time on
performance-- that makes sense.
Commuter rail has long
distance between stops.
It stops at every stop.
And most of the time
is spent in movement.
So the percentage of time
spent dwelling is small.
On the other hand, you have a
very long, high-frequency bus
route.
So the likelihood of
bunching here is really high.
And it's hard to control this.
AUDIENCE: Especially, also
the commuter rail, also it's
like a scheduled dwell.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, it's
a little longer
than it has to be.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] hold.
Then you don't
actually-- you have
a few seconds at the end where
no one is boarding or arriving.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, because you
might have printed
the schedule it has
departure times for every stop.
AUDIENCE: I would argue
that commuter rail has
sort of the most potential,
especially in a transit system
like Boston where you have--
well, the line acceleration, if
you get the acceleration better
through different
technology, and when
you don't have
high-level platforms,
the dwell times get
really long when you're
boarding a lot of people.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
But you still--
AUDIENCE: Plus then you could
pull the schedule down if you
were [INAUDIBLE] dwell time.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So you
could, if your schedule is off,
that could be an option.
Even if your schedule is good on
a high-frequency long urban bus
tour line, it's
not going to help.
You still have to control it.
And it's hard.
And you're going
to get bunching.
So dwell time depends
on many factors.
Some of them are human.
Some of them have
to do with modes,
as we just saw, operating
policies and practices,
weather, all these things.
So here is a list of models
of dwell times for trains.
So if we look at a
single door situation,
so people have to board and
alight from the same door
and there is no
congestion of passengers,
then this is the simplest
model one could have.
Dwell time is some
constant a, which
has to do with how
long it takes me
to come to a full
stop and open doors,
plus some amount times
the number of people
getting on plus some amount
times the number of people
getting off.
Does that make sense?
You sort of measure
the average number
of seconds per
passenger alighting,
the average number seconds
per passenger boarding,
and some constant.
You run a regression model.
That's what you get.
OK, now what if you notice
that, when the train is packed,
people take a lot longer
to get off and on?
Then you want to add the
effect of interference,
or congestion, or friction.
Some people call it friction.
So one way of doing
that is to multiply--
so we add a term, the
passenger friction term.
We multiply the
number of people that
were getting on and off
times the number of standees
in the vehicle.
STD here stands for standees.
So the number of people
getting on and off
are the people that would
have moved faster if there
hadn't been any standees.
And to the extent that there
are many standees, then
they encounter friction as
they are getting on or off.
And that slows the vehicle down.
So that's one way of
taking care of this.
If that car has
m doors, then you
could run a model for
every door and then pick
the door that was slowest.
So that's that model.
And if you say that, actually,
people are more or less
evenly distributed
inside the vehicle
and evenly distributed
on the platform,
so if we are willing
to assume that,
then we can just take the
number of doors and divide
by number of doors, essentially.
So we're back to
the previous model,
but now we're
multiplying-- or dividing
by m, by the number of doors,
because we have maybe 1,000
passengers or many
hundreds of passengers,
but we have to divide
by the number of doors
to bring them down to
passengers per door.
If that train has
several cars, then you
have a model for each
car in the train.
And you take the maximum,
so similar concept.
We were looking before
at doors in one car.
Now we're looking at
cars in one train.
And if that is
our balance flows,
again, we can now
divide by number
of doors per car and
number of cars per train.
So we normalize the demand
by the size of the train,
the number of doors.
And we include friction.
So here is some examples, some
ideas for your problem set,
if you want.
Some of them may apply.
Others may not.
So this is the kind of
thing you could think of.
So now we want to
look at this study
by Milkovits published in 2008.
At the time, there
had been some studies
with manually collected data.
So there was very limited
data on infrequent events.
There was very limited
data on crowding.
They were still using, I
think, the token system.
So the previous study was
based on the token system,
so it wasn't updated
on new fare technology.
So there was another study
that did have automatically
collected data, a
little more recent,
but they hadn't
taken into account
the effect of payment type.
So the AFC system does
tell you, this is a pass,
or this is a ticket, but they
hadn't-- they had ignored that
variable from the model.
And the fit of the
model was poor.
And then we have a transit
capacity and quality
of service manual, which says,
assume half-second penalty
per passenger for
crowding, so rule of thumb.
So there was interest
in developing something
more sophisticated.
And they looked at
buses and CTA for that.
So they looked at these
factors, so boarding, alighting
passengers, counting them,
onboard passengers, so load,
the fare media type, the
alighting door selection,
so whether people boarded--
alighted from the front door or
from the back door, which has
an impact, and the bus type.
There were several bus designs.
And some of them were-- had
wider doors and fare boxes
placed more optimally.
So all of that was
taken into account.
And yeah, so data from
the CTA in Chicago--
they didn't consider
timing points,
because at timing points,
buses can be held.
So that could be erroneously
included as dwell time,
so that was thrown out.
Only far-side stops--
so what's the difference
between a near-side stop
and a far-side stop?
AUDIENCE: Far-side stop
is after the intersection.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Right, after signals--
so far-side stops
are after signals.
They did not look at
near-side stops, which
could be affected by the
red light, the example
that Ari just gave of, as
the bus is ready to leave,
a light turns red.
Now you have a
longer dwell time.
The bus could leave its
doors open just in case.
So that was thrown out.
OK, they looked--
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by known stops?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So if
there were any stops that were
not properly coded or--
they were thrown out.
They had APC, so the Automatic
Passenger Counting, all doors.
And they threw out data
that was of bad APCs,
so buses that required zero
boardings or zero alightings
were thrown out.
And they looked at
each AFC transaction
and matched it to what--
how they paid.
Was it a ticket?
Was it a smart card, et cetera?
So they looked at a whole
month, November 2006.
So here's how the model works.
First, they realized
that it was easier
to have one model for when
the front door controls
the process and a separate model
for when the rear door controls
the process.
So the first step was to predict
which of the two processes
was going to dominate and
control the dwell time,
and then from that, select
that one model, or the, one
or the other.
And then they looked
at including bus type
and traveling as a friction
factor in each of these models.
So let's look at the
high-level results.
This is the front door model.
So this is for when the front
door dominates the process.
They had a pretty good
adjusted r squared, 0.733.
And we see some dummy variables.
NABI is a type of bus here.
And NOVA and New Flyer
are also types of buses.
So NABI, for some reason, tended
to be a half second longer
dwell time overall.
This variable is the number of
people getting on in the front.
They are excluding the first
few passengers for the reason
that Ari brought up
earlier in the lecture,
that the first few passengers
take a little longer,
but once you have a [INAUDIBLE],,
a stream of passengers
going in, then there's
a more uniform rate.
So this is front on extra.
And we have 3.7, about.
But it was a little longer for
NOVA buses and a little shorter
for NABI buses.
So you have to adjust that
amount for the different buses.
So there was an interaction
between that variable
and the dummies for bus type.
Then the effect of people
getting off in the front
was accounted for.
So here you have--
if you have three
or more people,
so people in excess
of three getting--
people in excess
of two, actually,
three or more people
getting off in the front,
that had an impact as well,
a positive impact, of course.
So these parts that
I described were
included in the
model for non-crowded
and in the model
for crowded as well.
So they have separate
parts of the model
that were for crowded and
non-crowded conditions.
When it wasn't crowded, cards
were about 2.6 second effect
for boarding per passenger.
Tickets were about 4.8,
so almost 2 seconds slower
than smart cards.
And New Flyer tickets were
not quite as longer as tickets
everywhere else.
So this is the bus that
had pretty wide doors
and the fare box was
placed in a better way
so that people could
tap in as they went in.
You have a small
advantage there.
Here you have the effect
of people getting off
in the front for the
first two passengers,
not the ones that are
three and up, so 2.8
seconds per passenger extra.
And here is a dummy for
if the sensor in the front
was blocked, which could
have different effects.
But essentially, that could
indicate crowding or something,
so that was included there.
What happens when
it was crowded?
So when the load on
the bus was high,
it didn't really matter if
it was a card or a ticket.
So now we're just regressing on
the number of AFC transactions.
And we're getting an average
of 4.3 per passenger.
So it's slower.
It's much closer to
the ticket quantity.
And therefore, the
impact, the benefit
that you had of dwell time
savings by smart card is lost.
So that savings, you have
when it's not crowded,
but you lose when it's crowded.
Sonya?
AUDIENCE: Is that the same thing
with off-board fare collection?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No, because when
you have off-board
fare collection,
you can open all doors.
And so it becomes more like a
train, where everybody gets off
first and then
everybody gets on.
So this model is for more
people boarding by the front
and alighting from the back.
But sometimes, some people
get off in the front.
And here we have
the friction factor,
so the number of passengers--
the number of standees
squared times passengers.
So this is going to--
it's a small factor,
a small coefficient,
but it's multiplied by
some quantity squared,
so that kind of makes
up the difference.
And because this
is squared, this
is kind of a polynomial effect.
So the more people
that are standing--
it's not a linear increase.
If there many more people on
the bus that are standing,
then it's a much slower dwell.
So this is a correction
factor for a crowded bus.
OK, here is the rear door model.
So this is for when the
rear door was predicted
to control the
dwell time, so more
towards the end of the route
where more people are getting
off than people are getting on.
We have, again, some impacts.
The design of vehicle
was significant.
And the number of people getting
off was, of course, a variable,
so about 1.7 seconds
per passenger--
more on NOVA buses,
less on NABI buses.
And the friction
factor, again-- so you
have the sort of general
friction factor was 0.005.
It was 0.009 for normal buses
and 0.002 for NABI buses.
So you have to sort
of add these up
to get the effective friction
factor on a particular bus.
All right, so the
sort of key takeaways
are that the smart
media loses the benefit
in crowded conditions.
We saw that.
The crowding impact
increases exponentially.
These people tried
linear standees.
And standees squared was
a much better predictor.
So bus attributes
impact dwell time.
The dummies for the bus
design were significant.
And they had an impact.
So some of that had to do with
the location of the ticket
reader.
And some of that had to do with
wide doors that allowed people
to enter more
comfortably and faster.
So that's good.
Let's move on to the
Green line model, just
quickly, at a high level.
We're almost out of time, so
I'm going to skip this slide.
You're, I think, all aware
of what the Green line is,
so I don't have to cover this.
They looked at one-car train
and two-car train models
separately.
So sometimes the
Green line will run
single vehicles, single
car, or sometimes
two cars paired together.
And the dwell time here was
some constant times the number
of people who are getting
on times the number--
plus the number people getting
off plus some friction factor.
And same here for two-car
trains, but the coefficients
were different.
So that's the overall concept
that I want to communicate.
Here is a table of the results
from that model for the number
of people getting on.
So this is using the
model to forecast.
These are not observations.
So if you feed 0 people getting
on, you just get the constants.
If you feed the model
10 people getting on,
it depends on the
load on the model.
If the load is,
say, less than 53,
then you don't have the
friction factor really
controlling anything, so
you have 20.3 or 20.2,
so a very small
effect of friction,
and therefore about the
same time for both models.
If it's very
crowded, then you do
have a more significant benefit
for having a two-car train.
That makes sense, right?
You have more capacity.
And the same thing
happens as you
move to 20 passengers getting
on and 30 passengers getting on,
with those differences
increasing when you have
a crowded train,
and the differences
between one-car
and two-car trains
not being that significant
when you don't have much
[INAUDIBLE].
So this should, more
or less, make sense.
So all this is to show you that
you have some ideas about what
controls dwell time.
You test your
hypothesis on the data.
And you can try
different things.
These are just examples.
So the findings from that
research, dwell times
were quite sensitive
to flows and loads.
The crowding effect
might be non-linear.
They looked at
non-linear effects .
Just like before.
The dwell times for multi-car
trains, for two-car trains
were different than
those for one-car trains.
The dwell time functions suggest
high sensitivity of performance
to perturbations.
So we saw what
those preparations
were earlier in this lecture.
And this model is
sensitive to some of them.
Because of that, effect of
real-time operations control
should be essential
to operating the Green
line with even headways.
So this is more of
a recommendation.
And another recommendation
is that simulation models
of this kind of
service should include
sophisticated dwell time
models like the ones that
were estimated here to
account for all those effects,
because otherwise, you would
have a simple model that is
not very faithful to reality.
Running a mixed fleet,
some with one-car trains,
some two-car trains
is dangerous.
So what do they
mean by dangerous?
So it wouldn't make much
difference if it's not crowded.
But according to the model,
on crowded conditions,
the two-car train
will be faster.
So then you will have a
bunching effect happening,
two-car trains catching
up to one-car trains,
and therefore deterioration
of service quality.
Here is a marginal
boarding time on heavy rail
from the third paper.
I think this was
looking at the Red line.
So this is the
marginal boarding time
when everybody can sit down.
When you look at the number
of through passengers--
that is the number of passengers
who are on the train when
the train arrives on the
platform and don't get off,
so passengers riding
through the station--
when the number is 0, then this
is how much boarding time you
have per passenger,
more or less.
And then as you look at the
effect of more and more people
are standing, than that
kind of slows people down
as they board.
So this was a way of
capturing that effect,
again, the fiction factor.
So you see a theme here, that
this seems to be relevant.
And there have been
research studies
looking at ways of including
that effect in models.
These models could
be used for improving
the accuracy of your
waiting time estimate
that your smartphone
gives you, or improving
how faithful a simulation
model is, et cetera.
Here is the equation,
very similar,
same structure we had before.
We have some constant.
We have the number
of people boarding
per door, the number of
people alighting per door.
In this case, we add
them up, because people
alight first and then board.
And then we have
some friction factor.
How that friction
factor is calculated
has been different
on every model,
but they all have
a friction factor.
So these are all services
that, at least at times,
are quite crowded.
So that was important
and significant.
OK, if there are no
questions, you may leave.
And if there are,
I'll take them.
Sorry, don't feel
that you have to wait,
because it's already 5:30.